okay hello everyone welcome to a wol
language design review I think this is
the tail end of some version
uh review of part of our language
completeness and consistency
series all right first up is a pet peeve
of mine for a while um which I'm looking
forward to seeing a great new version
of this is the
formatting drum roll I want to see this
oh is this what we agreed this this
superscript
thing it's uh pretty close to what we
agreed
um
you suggested that we stick it in
actually in the circle but I'm both
worried about the scalability of that
even more than I'm worried about the
scalability of this and you know at 100%
magnification it's pretty hard to read
four I see my only question is would it
not make more sense to have it be on the
other side of the
circle given that then then it would
look more like a fourth root type
thing do we have design folk here do we
have Jeremy here yeah I'm here but I
can't speak to like fourth route no I
understand but look let me show you what
we're emulating okay so if I do gosh how
do I get that in um I'd say x and I I do
the root how do I get to the root
position and then control five to get
to okay so that's the way that a four
through just okay yeah right but it's
the root I I mean but it's not
necessarily a fourth right it's a root
of a fourth order polinomial I mean yeah
right I mean it's slightly but but to me
this look it's like it's to the power
four whereas if if it was I mean if
somebody could just mock this of just
trying to put my idea was okay my idea
was to have the the four look let see if
I could do
it
okay so this was my idea to take
this take that
thing I don't know whether I can do this
but but um let's just make a
canvas am I going to be able to do
this this may be beyond
my abilities here but I was
thinking that we would
put the for crossing the circle like in
yeah I I just think that's crazy both
from an implementational point of view
and from a readability point of you I
mean right you've blown that up to what
font
size oh okay so I mean let me let me
unbl it I mean and um
uh I mean you're already at 125%
magnification okay Jeremy what what um
no I mean that was the mock was an
overlay but I think think I had it on
the right and you need to add a glow or
something behind
the so
work uh let me find
it right and I mean don't forget that
you know this can easily be you know a
hundred or a thousand I
mean how do I get is there a way we
could have click a copy for this thing
here um possibly although why would you
want it I mean you can just select it
and
copy I don't know and the font here is
really ugly but other than that I and
and and we don't usually have I mean
that's a code font why the heck do we
have a a comment in a code
font but I like this functionality in
general
okay well because I was focused on
content and not getting every single
detail uh styling detail
right okay but but but that's what we're
here for so let's let's um just right
well you asked why and I was answering
your question yeah okay fine fine and so
this thing go ahead Jeremy yeah I mailed
that mock if you want to take a look at
it
okay
okay so that's the previous one with the
overlay but it would have to I think
really think it should go on the left do
we have other mathy people here I I can
of agree the left looks kind of more uh
reasonable I mean this looks like like
you said to the power four
yeah Jeremy could we okay it's high
right right well so so let let me let me
let me point out that you know
for uh for transcendental equations I
put Infinity I certainly wouldn't make
sense on the left so we would either I
know I don't see that that's bad on the
left I think it's fine on the left I
think it's rather the the the Infinity
of root that that doesn't make any sense
to
me I think that nothing makes sense but
the infinity is a nice
idea well it makes to me it makes sense
on the right because talking about an
infinite degree polom right uh an
analytic function is just an infinite
degree polom I understand that that's
why I think it makes sense in the left
because it's a it's a root of an
infinite degree polinomial so it's kind
of like the infinite root because you're
trying to get down to that value in a
polinomial with X to the infinity plus
whatever okay I mean but but I have a a
different question which is big big
numbers here do you have examples of
that so I don't have very big numbers I
have uh oh that's 50 okay there's
50 right and you can see already at 50
it right I mean you couldn't fit that in
the in the circle no I I understand
that
um
we need a solution here I I just don't
think I think my immediate response was
it's to the power four here which just
seems
wrong okay implementation let me just
ask you this if if we were trying to do
this overlay thing is it is it easy to
implement or is it like unbelievably
hard to
implement I think uh an overlay would be
pretty difficult to implement you know
unless we you know unless we did un
unless we did like one through nine and
then 10
plus and right
it's John can you comment is John here
yeah yeah I'm here so can you comment on
how one would do this with an overlay
box or
whatever um so you're you want to
Overlay the number sorry I'm confused
are you talking centered now or left or
right or what are you talking about say
let's just say on the left but mostly
overlaid over the
circle yeah um well I mean
essentially yes it can be done with
overlay and spacer um quite reasonably
spacer or invisible uh either
one but I I think E's concern is that
uh getting it to look really really good
for an arbitrary digit like um he's
concerned about
yeah right so so yeah I guess if I if I
can leak into the left like that then
that's less of a concern I like this a
lot meaning wise to vanra do you want to
comment on that yes I totally agree this
looks more correct and if you can't see
it at Large enough numbers I think
that's okay I mean people don't write
root objects for 10th or 12th Roots even
you know so third fourth is I think two
digits is enough I
think if we went beyond two digits I'd
be perfectly happy to just see a dot dot
there or something like that yes and I
think because we that's the kind of
people whom we trying to cater to with
this type setting so I think that's fine
but I really like the yeah I think I I
like it design overall but this one
aspect I think changed to the left looks
it also gets out of the way of the
numbers you know
basically the actual uh decimal
approximation over there so one thing to
say just about the tweaks around this
specific or you know exactly what we're
looking at is uh the uh
uh so for the I mean in this case it's
really covering up the
circle um the best that the front end
can do
well uh you know without going deep into
hackery uh is going to be you know
essentially the
blackbox uh you know rectangle around
that around those
digits so this looks actually like it's
even a bit tighter than that and I'm
not I'm not sure it would be quite that
tight if you understand
meaning and is it obvious that we don't
want to just make this a piece of
Graphics well I I mean like make create
like two through nine or whatever and or
no I was I was thinking that we render
it as Graphics maybe that's
stupid right well I mean that is a
graphics right the the the circle is a
graphics and I either I could either
attempt to put you know uh the four on
top of it or integrate it as a you know
text directive inside
of I think it should be a text directive
inside the graphics to me okay I think
that's a much more likely you know so
long as there's no rendering time well
and so it would be a directive that has
a it either has a background or there
would be an additional rectangle um to
make it to make it obscure the circle
yes uh the additional rectangle is
problematic because you need to measure
exactly the size of the of the fonts uh
John John wouldn't a glow or something
like that work I don't think you need to
one of our modern
background um well I mean the problem is
that glow is uh in order to do it enough
to get the entire inside of the zero it
might it might go farther than you want
outside of the zero if you know what I
mean and doesn't it like use the GPU and
crazy stuff like that what is I'm sorry
I guess I'm behind the times can
somebody explain to me what glow is like
Drop shadowing in that family it's it's
a pixel shading effect
AC uh yes you're behind the times wait a
minute why is this not yeah do I have to
put it in a graphics and and and it's
and it's not it's not glow it's it's
it's
Halo
hello where is
it do I say in text primitive there yes
yeah yeah
um come on you set a background the uh
that's not the way you use drop
shadowing in just open the
documentation oh it's a directive inside
of it's like red it's yeah why does this
open in in the web documentation CU you
probably don't have the 141
documentation installed yet right it's a
prototype you only got the
141 builds installed this morning so I'm
not surprised you don't have the
documentation I'll uh I'll I'll mention
that to Roger
okay why doesn't anything go yellow here
sorry I'm I'm just worrying about this
so that's yellow in
thate it's because of the mismatched
brackets this is
but why is this not yellow because
because you have unbalanced brackets and
this is a feature in the Prototype build
I'm aware I know I I know what this is
I'm just I'm confused by why I mean this
may explain what some things that I've
been utterly confused by in in the way
that this whole um so I mean this is
still yellow yes because you have
balanced
brackets and you have balanced brackets
now if you delete one of those brackets
things will start turning not
yellow I see but I get back to Yellow
this is nice now I understand this
better
John okay this is really not bad and I
like the effect of having I I see the
Pink goes with the pink of this yep yeah
yes
exactly this is quite
nice wow good idea okay in any case that
wasn't what we were looking for here but
but what we're looking for here is is
some uh okay that was very small there
but but you get the message
um right it's just a it's just a
different form of shadowing haloing
whatever else it
is
oh and I like the fact that in when it
goes
red to what extent is this consistent
when it goes red from a syntax error is
that consistent with the
pinking
um okay so that's pink yeah and now let
me try and evaluate it and what
was now now it's it's repined I mean
that that pink is the same pink that I
had before or that's it's now a
different pink you know it probably
isn't exactly that's more of a red yeah
that's but this this behavior is is not
new uh no I know that's not new but I'm
saying it could be consistent with the
the thing okay so that's
now I understand okay so that's
pink and then when it's errored out go
ahead yeah it seems right that it's not
quite aired out yet right you're still
editing you can fix it it's not quite
set in stone that it's a
problem I agree I think it's pretty
good yeah well I mean any way you slice
it this isn't going into 14 there's more
subtlety than what we've covered here
and I W to I want to make sure that
we've plumed the depths of it um I'm sad
because I think it's really
nice okay in any case we'll get some
version of this I think Beyond two
digits
um I mean do we try and go to three
digits maybe and then I mean
algorithmically Beyond two digits are we
still swimming or is this thing like
grinding to a halt when it gets me up
Beyond about two digits in the
exponents what do you mean by this thing
I mean root objects if I had a root
object with do you mean grinding on the
rendering of it or I mean the
algorithmic side of it
okay you you you can go up to Millions I
mean we have examples with root with
degree
million root objects okay well then I
think we need
something
uh how what what would be our overflow
thing I mean I think the infinitive for
the transcendental is kind of cool but
what is our large but
finite is it dot dot is it a single
digit dot dot is it
in nah yeah I was thinking I it would
just be like what whatever our cut off
is if our cut off is 99 then we'll then
have a greater than
99 as the as the object seems arbitr
what about okay question this is a math
question I mean what's more important
the first digit or the last digit in the
exponent the first I mean oh starting
from the left you mean like yeah because
I mean you want to get a sense
of no I think I what's actually
important the two things that are
important are either the number of
digits or the last digit because you
know it certainly matters if it's an
even or odd
yes yeah you know just knowing that the
first digit is three but not knowing if
that's you know 30 or
30,000
is fine I think a I wonder if we could
have something like one do do four or
whether that would be even more
confusing or we could have like dot do
five right
[Music]
um yeah we could have dot dot five or
yeah I don't know that we want to go
that big we could do sort of a short
style you know first digit number of
missing digits yeah that's too compated
I don't think we need that
okay yeah I I think we should go okay
okay so let's all right so I think we've
agreed what what that's going to look
like now let's talk about
this say do we need the
circle yes okay yeah I thought of that
too yes we need need it it's a branding
thing because it isn't exactly a root
and it's not you know you're not taking
the root of this thing it's just a it's
just an iconic element yes
okay
okay so let's talk about
this
um this is fine but okay so first it
says root
here right I don't understand yeah go
ahead the reason for that is that there
are well there are at least two
different heads that will use that icon
and we're going to be using a similar
sort of styling although with a
different icon for finite field so my
thought was that we would have a heading
with the with the head um just much like
we do in information and whatnot um and
then you know
details um so for example if you looked
at one of the system of equation things
then
um you'll see that my sentence does not
start with capital
root yeah okay but I understand that I
I'm I guess I'm asking I was sort of
thinking this would be um a raft of some
kind that just
says I mean I I just don't understand
why this wouldn't be clicked to copy
here because that's the main event of of
I want the the the um uh you know
polinomial out of this thing minimal
polinomial I mean what else could I want
from it from this root object the degree
the minimal polinomial those are the
things
right um
for um if it's a polom then those are
probably the things you want yes if it's
a
transcendental expression what do I want
then then you might want the
multiplicity if it's a root cluster you
might want to have the the computed
approximate
location
um but presumably I can get that from
n
well you can get you can get the the
equation using first right I mean yeah
but I don't to do your whole objection
was that you you you you that you didn't
want to do this
programmatically well I want to know how
to do it programmatically I I didn't
know how to do it programmatically I had
no idea that I could just use First on
this most you know raw objects don't let
you just use first it's not a raw object
well I didn't know that looks like a raw
object walks and talks like one but it
isn't a raw object okay so it's right
normally with with summary boxes don't
we have kind of like a more tabular
thing like equation colon right so so
that that's the alternate styling that's
a few rows above that I only did for the
polinomial case which is you know I
didn't think it uh would necessarily
scale as well but if if you think this
is a better look I can I can go in this
direction what other things other than
univariate polinomial there's univariate
polinomial there's transcendental
equation there's transcendental well
it's the five things that are listed
there right transcendental equation
transcendental root cluster sorry where
is oh I see triangular polinomial system
and system of transcendental
equations what the hell are these here
those are the two pols that make make up
to the the Triangular
system and why isn't that just in a
list uh
because I thought the well if if they're
large I think the scales better only if
you can click to copy them I mean I
don't want to have to go and click and
this and then that and assemble that and
so on okay I strongly prefer this but
the fonts are
wrong okay
um I mean Jeremy we've done so many of
these things like this before I mean we
tend to use the Sans text font right for
these kinds of things am I
right it's on mute but yeah I used it in
that first case we looked at under
alternate styling I mean so we just
apply that visual style I think that
looks like source with
a this is we normally use some kind of
helvetica like you know compact font not
this kind of code font we don't want a
code font we certainly don't want a code
font for a piece of text
here we can have a code font for this
but I mean okay this is not hard guys
it's really not hard and and summary
boxes I think we always use code
font not for labels though should be
Source ss pro for labels okay it's
possible it's been a while since I've
dug into those just text font yeah and
I'm not sure why we're not just going
vertical for everything
here going vertical for everything I I
don't know why we have this vertical
paaths I I think that's a mistake I I
think it's just going to be confusing
you know given that I I just I just
thought it would would be you know
wasteful especially if if you think the
main event is the polinomial well okay
fair enough I mean all right okay I
agree this is reasonable this is
reasonable it's just this is such an
ugly font it it put me off
okay um this looks okay to
me okay but but I mean in in the case of
something but everything should be
labeled and I think it should have
clicked a
copy okay there no real reason it
doesn't um well I mean and if the
polinomial is huge you don't want to
manually try to select it to copy anyway
yeah yeah actually that actually that
reminds me of something that crossed my
mind earlier is there ever a case where
uh the polinomial is so huge we may not
want to show it in its
entirety I think
yes uh there probably is uh I don't know
what that case is um well you can click
on my degree 50 polinomial
there
right I mean that's yeah that's not
highly
useful yeah so there might be some kind
of size limiter iconized type thing that
that once again would would have a click
a copy around
it right where the click to copy is
really the main
event
okay finite fields
right so this is taking the basically
the existing object but applying this
styling to it which is what we
uh
um right and if we want to switch to the
some more summary boxy style you know
that's easy enough to to do yeah I think
this is basically good and I think this
is much more compact I don't remember we
have before but this is much more
compact than that yeah well if you copy
that into another notebook it'll go to
the current styling
[Music]
and oh yeah this is unbelievably much
better than
you however um I'm wondering if there's
any way we can sort of separate
off you know I wonder whether we could
have a vertical separator inside the
lozen box here between the F3 and the
two
which we effectively have in this case
by having the circle around the thing
but I'm just
suggesting a you know what I'm saying a
vertical yeah just just a pipe like I
was using above yeah except that I think
it should span the the from floor to
ceiling uh okay depending on how that's
well I might need to change my
implementation in order to do that but
uh well so okay so if you literally want
it from floor to ceiling
I don't know how to do that because uh
if I were put a grid box in there inside
the how can we do this yeah sorry my my
attention wandered a bit what what do
you mean by floor to ceiling from the
from the lower to the upper you you want
what from floor to ceiling I want a
separator line that's blue or ah ah okay
okay um yeah so
uhi you should talk to Lou
this is not easy he's done things that
are a bit like it and it's uh uh he can
tell you the hacks to to to make this
work right I mean right the point is
that you know it's a right that there's
a frame box there with a rounded corner
so if we even if we were to stick to a
grid then it won't get all the way to
the top Jeremy does it need to get all
the way to the top and
bottom or if it's the full height of the
yeah I think if it's very close it's
fine I don't think it it's not going to
kill us to miss a pixel or two there
well and and and I think it might be
possible to glue two frame boxes
together um and you can individually
control the rounding on frame box
Corners okay okay now you know it that
may if selectability is an issue that's
going to mess up selectability but uh
of the contents um but there are options
um we can figure it
out all
right ready to ready to go on to the
next item
yep
okay so basically I did what was easy to
do in terms of the WID coloring there
there is a hard thing you know this is
like you know a half a day's work and I
knocked out 90% of it but the remaining
10% is you know a multi-day
project
um uh which is that uh it just to be
clear uh that in that first example the
A on the right hand side should have
been green because it's being
scoped uh uh by because the the A and
the second you wrote that as two nested
wids right if if you copied that first
input and in the second argument add a
width bracket and
then
um yeah so that is the correct coloring
but
getting you know the uh uh the the the
frontends syntax highlighting system is
uh uh is fragile um and getting this
sort of thing to work requires real
effort but uh but what we're proposing
is that we've got this much working and
that uh while it's you know in some
fundamental senses not correct it it
might good enough to
finally
14.1 or even 140 I I'm not going for it
I I don't like this very much I really
think we should try and get this right I
think this is very confusing when I
write code and I have blue variables in
there it bothers me a
lot this is one of my few abil you know
places where I can kind of make sure
things are scoped correctly I I really
don't think it should get blown up like
this I mean I'm sorry I I I wish it
well I mean you don't have to apologize
except that you left a very distinct
impression that compromises were
acceptable when we last talked about
this and I I did not internalize just
what level of compromise this was I mean
in other words I I really don't think
this is a good idea to leave something
blue here I mean even if you could turn
it black I'd be
happy but I doubt you can do
that it it would by the time I could do
that I could turn it any color
yeah
okay look I think we should plan on this
for 141 and we should try and get it
right I I just don't think we should let
people have something where you know
we've gone through so much trouble and
and by the way I mean this case here I
would like to see some of those things
red I mean that's clearly wrong but but
it's not red it's it's that's I mean why
would it be red because it's wrong
because
because you can't have a width with just
an X there well sure but we don't have
that level of
coloring yes we do we have plenty of
coloring like that no we don't give me
one
example um doesn't plot color would like
that
doesn't well we should have that
coloring I mean this is not probably for
this meeting it's probably for the user
assistance discussion but I it would be
great if that colored red that would
catch errors I'd made right and and we
we do have some coloring about you know
single equals versus double equals uh
yes but it's I'm just saying but but but
it's a you know I have filed bug reports
about how incredibly fragile and buggy
to the point okay fine but it's better
than nothing and the fact is that the
error that is you know the current with
error of saying with you know xal 1
you know
XY that should turn red and it does in
the previous version and you know
because that should be X semicolon Y and
I mean I think we're losing something by
not having that turn
red and it should turn red I mean this
case look okay I'm sorry I'm sorry well
this this says this is not turning red
because we've right because I know
I'm saying we know that the Syntax for
with is brace symbol equals blah it has
to be that if it isn't that it should
turn
red well
and so I'll I'll just take that as a
given here but you know as a more
General note I mean this is the sort of
thing
where you know I'm pretty good with our
language but I don't spend all of my
time language lawyering all the details
and there's you know there are cases
where it's not clear to me where you
know uh I mean like for example uh the
second argument of of
plot uh is typically a list but the
language you come something but but but
you can find ways to write legitimate
plot statements that work without that
and I uh you know I'll I'll I'll just
take what you're saying as a given for
width but for anything else I mean
there's a certain level of language
lawyering that I would need some
assistance with okay this is and and I
just put something in the chat yeah oh
yeah sorry about the ins and outs but
yep so my my point is it's proog it's
possible to programmatically create a
correct wi yep
yep I mean this is where user assistance
should be going is is being able to tell
whether you're doing this or whether
you're doing
this I mean yeah you can
programmatically feed things in and you
know I mean that's the question right so
so you can't unconditionally color that
I know but but the fact is it's 99% of
the time it's a
mistake and that's what we're doing
that's the whole point of syntax
coloring you know do we think that this
is I
mean I think it's worth I don't know I
don't know and you know if we had a
mechanism to switch off the syntax
coloring in other words if it came up
red and we had a raft essentially which
said like spell correction turn off the
syntax coloring then well we we do have
we do have uh you know various syntax uh
colorings are exposed in the preferences
dialogue way too Global but but but but
but some cases people have wanted Global
I mean people have wanted for example to
say uh no every time I put a single
equal in the first argument of of if I
don't ever want to hear about that again
I know I know I know that's but I think
it's much more common that people are
going to want to do
this and that will be a really nice
feature I mean in other words we would
be able to do a lot more rening if we
had a mechanism like spell correction
to kind of ignore that
reding see what I'm saying so um I
mean there's a philosophical issue
around this um which is I mean
fundamentally there are two ways to be
looking at code uh one is code AS boxes
and the other is code as uh symbolic
Expressions um and the you know the
reason why it's difficult to make
changes in the in the front end syntax
highlighting is because the front front
end syntax highlighting uh can only look
at boxes
yep um and so and in part our times
that's the only possible thing because
you're in the middle of typing things so
there is no right exactly where whereas
for example the the uh the static
analysis story is looking at symbolic
Expressions I'm well I'm well I'm a well
and so yeah I mean we have to think
about how much work we're willing to
invest in looking at things at boxes
where you know getting something to work
is just like 10 times as much effort I
know I and I I I'm not saying that to to
specifically disagree with a specific
proposal you were making I'm just saying
there is a general like make the
following comment if it came through
asynchronously like spellchecking does
and readen this on an asynchronous pass
I'd be perfectly
happy right once the expression is
complete do an asynchronous pass or once
this section of the expression is
complete in other words you clearly know
you're admitting you know because you're
yellow or you're
pink right so in in the case where it is
yellow then doing asynchronous you know
pass is that
crazy well I mean that's where we talked
about taking the static analysis story
but but static analysis is presently is
presently underpowered in in development
resources
so
right which we need to talk about
separately but that's a different issue
but I think um
that's what I would do I mean if if it's
if it if it is so much harder I think it
is more okay two points first of all the
ability to switch off a
rening um and second of all the
uh um I think that really opens up a lot
of opportunities and second of all the
asynchronous
pass Sandra on our Liv stream is asking
about an obvious question in a nested wi
with the same
variable I think that's
okay I don't see a problem with
that right that's no that's no different
from if you did
to or would that would would that not
work I actually actually don't know what
would happen if you did it with the
proper nested
widths let's find out yeah would that
that that could probably break you did
it with nested wids unless it it it does
not break uh the
front so so the internal renaming
mechanism recognizes them as local
variables and yeah so so then I think I
think the behavior is
fine
right because those are at the same
level of scoping so I I I think this
behavior is entirely
sensible okay but but that raises
actually another subtlety in terms of
the ideal with syntax
highlighting um the ideal with syntax
highlighting would in in the case that
sander raises uh uh would color the
second a
red um as an advisory that that you're
doing something maybe you didn't
intend which
I exactly as with the uh nested case
that's on I don't think that's bad yeah
I think I think you are doing something
wrong if you duplicate the variables
even if it works and I'm surprised that
it works I'm surprised it didn't become
with three equals four and and and there
there are lots of these uh scope
conflict cases where you know a thing
quotequote works but the purpose of the
syntax highlighting is you may not you
you may not realize what you just
did and I would compare it to the case
where I say with a equals a because a is
a module variable and but but now I need
to inject it into a held expression and
so I and so I like saying with a equals
a
because it's because I'm making it clear
that I'm injecting it but it the a in
the the width variable turns red because
it duplicates a module
variable
right
um
okay let's uh let's keep going
here okay well so I I mean that that's
one one thing that tells me is uh yeah
so I guess I'll just uh keep this out as
an unmerged Branch then until more until
more work goes into it um I think we
need to
uh
[Music]
um and I think we need to do more work
there but I really do think people can
continue to blame me for not having
varag with so sadly there you go
um I think the work is important and I
think that this you know the things we
just described are you know worthwhile
directions all right let's quickly try
and talk about co- identity
says right so this was a suggestion from
Nick um which you can see there it's the
thing which when eaten by anything gives
the
head um so Ian sort of mentioned that he
right so just like identity and
composition commute with f goes to map
of f then co- identity and this
co-composition operation he commute with
the mapping between you know X and
copping stuff onto X okay so let's just
remind ourselves so
coap of f
X like this goes to this yep okay so
what is co-
composition so
co-composition
is the thing
that
um if you well it's defined right there
yeah I can see
it I mean to me this is part of the
family of issues of sort of head related
patterning or nested you know CU we we
don't have just like we have double
blank to represent an arbitrary sequence
of arguments we don't really have
anything to represent F of f of f of f
of f any number of nested
times which seems like it's related to
this or am I
wrong I mean this would give us that I
mean in other words this isn't quite
that what is if I were to say let me
just go ahead and do this
this well actually I'm not even sure I
can do this but I mean if I were to say
f blank of
co-composition of X double
blank what the heck would that
do or is that
irrelevant
[Music]
um what would that be defined as I mean
isn't that be it would be something like
you know F at at reverse of list well no
not even that no it isn't that it's like
a it's like a fold isn't it right yeah
well as a like in N right it would evate
immediately but if you hold this pattern
then it's
just going to be well whatever it
is co composition doesn't do anything
useful here
okay but I mean what I'm what I'm
looking for is something that is a
pattern that
matches f of x
of you know okay so let's say I wanted
to match f of x x x x x how would I
match that what is that
pattern or that's one pattern or F of f
of f of f of f of f whatever it is
of
X right and you know I don't think
co-composition or k identity have much
to say about
this I had something like this
implemented in the patterns I think I
called the Deep pattern something like
this so that you can it's more related
to the repeated but you go in depth
rather than in width of your expression
yes I mean it's like kind of like head
repeated does that make any
sense well it doesn't have to be a head
I think just any
expression well but but you kind of
construct I
mean right I mean had repeated would
would match one of those but not the
other right in one you have a repeated
head and the other you have
a compound head of you know repeated sub
fuess or
something but we don't have a pattern
for this we don't have a patent for
either of these things
no okay but you say that's irrelevant to
co-
identity correct because co- identity
you know just like map you know just
like default map lives at level one and
Co and coap by default lives at lives at
level one so does co- identity and
identity okay so if I say
map
identity onto X and Y I get X and Y
yep and are you saying that if I
co-map co
identity second
argument so you'd have like list FG
yep oh my
gosh right and I'm you know I don't
think that either Ian or I are clamoring
for this but you know it is something
that exists given that can exist given
okay so that's the minimal case right
which is maybe what you would giving
that y
yep anybody who's thought they were
dealing with traditional math functions
which they better not have because
transformation rules for symbolic
Expressions aren't really
that that will be deeply blown up and
okay anybody knowing in the category
Theory world is this the
thing if f is a
morphism this is kind of objectifying
the morphism
somehow that makes sense turning the
morphism into an
object right well it's
it's
um right it's looking at
the you know it's looking at the
functionals you know element goes to F
appli to
element and this is sort of the
identity functional for
that
right this is an argument-based head
extractor
yes this a very weird
object so what would be F of Co identity
comma
one exactly what you're WR
yeah
yeah yeah so I'll point out this is
possible because you can have more than
one argument but you can't have more
than one
head indeed because our expressions are
trees not
dags
yep right and that returns unevaluated
just like f of identity would return
unevaluated right that that's the
same that's the co of this
yep and
uh yeah am likely
the
um is there a
way because identity of
identity gives you you know what I'm
saying identity of identity gives you
identity what's the co- version of
that uh so what you're doing there is
you're saying composition of identity
comma
identity right yep if you did co-
composition of co- identity and co-
identity that's the co of
that all right what's a use case for
this
creature right so Nick had came up with
that one use case which is the final
bullet point I don't know if that's
really that
compelling yeah it's not very common but
the idea is just every time you have
this kind of active property just just
Returns the same kind of object it may
be useful it's like whether you have to
M mutate it or you don't if you have
some
condition so like usually in the usual
case with identity you can I often write
like if some condition satisfies I do
something and if I doesn't I just apply
identity yeah I agree I
agree yeah so that's that's Au case for
co- identity I'm unaware of au's case
for co- composition which is like feed
in arguments one at a
time right
but co-
identity what's really
weird is this is return ret turning
ahead it's one thing to return the
argument you know nothing happened it's
just identity it just passes through but
to return ahead that's really
weird agreed I I think this is for wfr
for right now I think it's worth us you
know when we really are feeling very uh
sort
of you know theoretically inclined I
think we should tackle I think we should
consider consider both thisa these cases
here and multi-level up
values and whether there's a way to
represent
those and these are somewhat related I
claim because by the time you have these
Stacks head
Stacks you know if you could ponify a
headstack you are effectively
you know something which would because
an up
value you could think of as blank of
blank of blank blank a blank of f
of let's see what am I thinking of yeah
I mean you can think about it as some
kind of pattern for the headstack can
you
not all right I think I should run off
here but I think I think this is not a
thing for right now although we should
wfr both Co co- identity and
co-composition because they are
interesting language constructs and it's
a great exercise for for thinking about
this but not for right
now okay but before you finish I have I
have one other micro point about the
width highlighting yep um I I was just
writing this up for my notes and I
realized that uh if you want red
highlighting uh you don't want to and I
just want to make sure that we're on the
same page here I don't think you ever
want to highlight the final argument
which you want to highlight is uh things
that aren't the final argument that
aren't list of assignments yep I agree
and so in your like with ABC D you would
highlight a b and c as red the D would
not be that's what I think yeah that's
exactly what I think okay sounds good
all right see you guys soon
bye bye
bye